[Music]
very honest honest artists table instead
nose ha Sinestro few loss Carmela
Marquis LeMay hos Cana Mariano's pantos
de nuestra contigo gnostic or me go into
service Panamera Oregano's que no se lo
único que no
[Music]
cuando see wavy areas a pool table yo
senti algo una cosa mirada como que
[Music]
cuando yo ultimate ela trabajando en
Emiliana giant Robin air toma de las
cuatro natal de negocios de niro
Princesa entonces egg ma pa da makea
yell send open evo a la marcha Dante
vallenato esto se le shell waggy my
inner ear echo Pawnee stay habla en su
misión chain may Allah say see auras
Ianto a estos no no no quiero ver lo no
quiero ver lo Tokyo siempre Pomona mokey
arose in 2001 the term femicide emerged
as a way to describe violence against
women because they are women when
thinking about femicide the first thing
that we want to remember is that
femicide is a global phenomenon femicide
is not unique to Juarez Mexico however
right now
since 2004 the femicides have increased
[Music]
onde está annamaria - Silencio calamari
ah no no quads con sol de ellos también
tiene todo lo que quieras Pro no holy
spumoni see home in Origo nadie en el
Cana Mariano Stan West at this table
instead leone hasta Tomi puesto de table
Makela yo maud ra la foto pequeña que no
tenia post yo no tenia photo
near-unanimous en la Chiquita quadrature
Chiquito me ah de Remy potent make we'd
taken serie de trabajo la Makela de
freitas casa machi de por maquila
Colonia populonia brentano casino am
bestow a my friend Obispo Vita Engadine
Asya nada en que no que no que no one
thing I try to do in my work is to talk
about critically what are the conditions
that give rise to femicide
[Music]
businesses don't want to come and set up
shop if there is negative attention so
the government talks about femicides the
killing of women and girls in Mexico as
a dark legend the activists and the
mothers will not let this escape public
attention one of the ways that mothers
and activists do this is by painting
crosses
[Music]
scenario el directo Serio cuenta en caso
de Mesa del Acadia tostado porque eres
una noche en escuelas de sex ooh porque
yo no tenían ninguna for cuando en medio
que quiero más estamos pronoun quad Rito
yay me dijo Mira mija kwaneese yo tengo
re-enforce to Dana Maria siempre da de
da de Bono's mi policías que no no phony
avast agus photos porque tu eres una
persona de bajo so when you look at the
disappeared women in pratas these are
not the affluent these are typically
poor women when the free trade
agreements happened most of the rural
areas of southern Mexico were decimated
so what happened is that workers in the
southern states of Mexico were forced to
migrate to look for work in the factory
settings
if a woman disappears in Ciudad Juarez
there are often no family members there
to look for them todos se murió el otro
mez parent rain SS amedeo para que para
sa scenario may sabe aaron todo que debe
encontrar when Poland even el Cerullo
Santa Maria Lusignan poor difícil en de
perro no metiendo me dieron antifa
Camilo cuerpo kami diay dentista la ropa
de
cuando yo me Sally comida here oh no
dead mystery Listeria display assess
inada yo la de necessary Al's
they say energy inaudible since I'm
young whooping again so do we know that
patriarchy is again a global phenomenon
but we also want to think about what the
conditions are in Mexico finding these
bodies is typically done by the family
members state officials have not been
investigating these crimes often the
government would say she's out with a
boy she's out on the wrong side of town
she was a prostitute she was drinking
they articulate the women as living
these double lives in my interviews with
several of the family members after the
femicides occurred many of the men in
relationships would say to their woman
comments like if you act out if you
start showing your independence you two
are going to end up a victim
the role of the state has been taken on
by the mothers of the victims and the
activists they have been for years
holding rest rails or searches out in
the desert to look for remains that
creates a double trauma because the
initial trauma was the femicide but the
trauma then that is taken on by the
family members having to go and search
for their loved ones search for clothing
search for bones in the desert is
another set of trauma and these restrain
our doing the work of the government yet
restore Maina no team en toe my AMARG
Arun estaba el carro de named hermano
December mana
el Michiko que cuando mi millibar on a
los potala estaba en SE que esta
diciendo lo mismo so AJ okay you wanna
know stop to Anita Alvarez casa dos
meses in a row gada y cuando me a
gerenuk where Lee mija
igualmente me drogar massages como tengo
no se CN Birla lo que you say poo canaan
funky on san rafael sale fulfilling me
how wanna form homicidal Kuato
and so one of the things we want to
consider is who is culpable
[Music]
there are many activists who talk about
the fact that American citizens can be
crossing into wadis and targeting the
women one man that I interviewed was
working in Juarez as an investigative
journalist and he said that many of the
men that he would interview that crossed
from El Paso would tell him if you want
to rape and murder a woman there is no
easier place than Ciudad Juarez and that
is because of the impunity
[Music]
no one is held responsible the
government doesn't want the public to
think that these women were real and
therefore crimes continue and that then
feeds into a culture quando C will be
areas of table yes empty alguna Kosambi
Barada into sigma bond Amalia man listen
to me man skinny sending man mija
tranquila enter Romeo Ghana bio que
tiene que tiene me no se lo siento mana
siento nada no están en tone cigar a
phone antenna say go lacunar re oh yeah
Dario Freitas la casa de Holly evolve ei
ver las casas la vuelta negra Loara
yo dijo que no era square flame eita
porque tu sabes que cuando paso caso de
mundo que se mueven familiar supermoon
hijo so maro papa KO SI es tu sientes
cuándo es tu hija cuando NOS tuica OCS
typically one thing that people want to
know is how can we address the issue of
femicide what can we do one of the ideas
was to boycott some of the corporations
that own the maquiladoras however when
speaking with the workers they asked
individuals not to boycott because that
would then mean a job loss for them so
it's very important the first thing I
always say is we need to speak with the
community members themselves the
community members are the ones embodying
and living this reality they are the
ones that are on the front lines
engaging in the activism our role is to
act in solidarity with them in whatever
capacity that we can but we follow their
lead projects like the faces of femicide
murals are extremely important what the
faces of femicide does with the work of
lluvia and MUC la vie au is interview
the mothers about their daughters lives
what were their dreams what were their
aspirations what were they studying what
did they want to accomplish to show the
world that this was an actual human
being and the government cannot erase or
engage in cultural amnesia
entonces si avez Amica me Trigorin una
maid en de gusto es Oh creamy lo que yo
prefiero me invest a Segrest our bloke a
tango que viene siendo su casa
this vamos a la casa para que me
property res sanam e-juice comentários
feminine Addison's eons de que aunque to
regress em okay del necessary Honoka
Falana rangas see Kazuya priestess a.22
vivienda for Mariota written Laurie
Segall todo que nadie lo que me Rico
suey
pero no me siento bien porque tengo
tantas otra vez de Nieva kannada no solo
que quiera one of the things that's also
really important to remember is that we
cannot engage in stereotyping and
currently what's going on with the Trump
administration is it functions to just
fuel those negative stereotypes Mexican
is rapists Mexicans as criminals these
poor brown women
no these are women with agency these are
women leading social movements these are
women with unique stories rape against
women is a global phenomenon gendered
violence is a global phenomenon this is
in no way shape or form a Mexican
problem or something inherent to a
Mexican sensibility well tell you
whenever you make it with them here this
thing which you mustn't let me look
anything you see more is a member you
know pumpkin is to understand which
imagine that matching kakuka against
them messin up in the setup imitating
ponies
keep understand Sarah open theater is a
little Mika oh yes Akira you look into
producer packing hidden camera see Cathy
he the person looking
[Music]